philippe guiguen première adjoint au
maire et tête de liste les clés avec
vous 2020 a présenté 14 engagements sur
la transition écologique proposer une
alimentation biologique dans la
restauration collective protéger la
ressource en eau ou encore donner la
priorité aux mobilités actives sont les
quelques sujets abordés lors de cette
table ronde
nous avons décidé de signer le pacte de
transition écologique pour 14 de nos des
préoccupations principales
nous allons donner à l'assemblée qui
sera là des exemples par rapport à ce
pacte de transition écologique pour
démontrer que même au niveau d'une
commune nous pouvons agir dans le cadre
cette transformation écologique
trente-cinq personnes ont rejoint
l'adjoint au maire qui a finalisé sa
liste son programme mené principalement
sur les notions environnementales sera
présenté dans les jours à venir
sophie stucki colistière a rejoint la
campagne de philippe dit guen pour son
engagement écologique on est nombreux
aussi avoir conscience des enjeux du
réchauffement climatique
on est nombreux aussi à avoir envie de
ré enchanter un peu l'écologie de dire
ben voilà 25% de canton
deux baisses d'émissions des gaz à effet
de serre quand on est individuelle mais
en terme collectif on peut faire aussi
beaucoup mieux donc on avait envie de
s'engager collectivement donc avec la
jeunesse de la liste mais aussi
justement les plus anciens la prochaine
réunion publique de philippe guiguen se
tiendra le 6 mars prochain
la maire sortante véronique côté millard
ne se représentant pas la liste les clés
avec vous 2020 et pour l'instant face à
trois autres listes